Kimberly is in North Carolina Kimberly
tell me your of I've had it moment well
mine Dave involved oranges
I was working 80 plus hours a week a
full-time job in two part-time jobs
decided I would like to have some
oranges went to buy them had no money
had maxed out credit cards and I threw a
full on show you crazy fit in the
Walmart right next to the orange bin and
I live in a very small town so it did
not take very long before my mama calls
wanted to put my crazy away so about
four minutes into crazy I realized that
I was having this argument with God out
loud and I have walked straight into the
ugly cry and told him all about how he
was not taking care of me all right
there in the produce section right there
next to the orange bin section at
Walmart we're having a spiritual
engagement with God yeah letting him
know how his word was false $5 frickin
bag of oranges so after I got my crazy
put away and my mama calm down when I
told her what it was over she donated
[Laughter]
oranges in the Walmart do not argue with
God he's got the last word because he
thinks he's God
what did you do then well I came home
putting the crazy away got myself
settled down and started praying and I
realized that if you're having a full-on
fit about $5 freaking oranges you may
not be doing math really well and I am
nobody's mastered but I can add and
subtract pretty well so it figured out
fairly quickly that I was not doing
things the right way so what was your
income at that point in your life I was
at about 37 a year and I had eight maxed
out credit cards a car payment medical
debt and a mortgage how long ago was
this that was 11 years ago what'd you do
in that frame of time I had never heard
of Dave Ramsey and God just sent me a
plan that remarkably is similar to Dave
Ramsey's plans and it actually is how my
mother and grandmother handled money and
I went to that used to be called common
sense yes and they did teach it to me I
just left it along the wayside while I
developed my own crazy so I decided that
I could not live like that anymore
I had had enough enough people had seen
me lose my crap right there in the one
minute I didn't need to be doing that
again not in the produce section of
Walmart so now 11 years later where are
you well in that time I also underwent a
downsizing that I thought I was going to
lose my job had to return back to school
and to things that do not go together
our menopause and algebra so it took me
a while but through all of that I paid
off every debt I paid off my mortgage
and I am completely debt-free
unbelievable now here's how God really
delivers off a $5 bag of oranges the job
that I thought I was going to lose and
sent me screaming to a community college
to get better education I now have a
position I could not possibly have
dreamed of what do you make now around
56
what do you do I'm in
the medical industry in Quality
Assurance your rock star and you're a
lot of fun yeah when they tell you God
worked through all things authors say he
worked for oranges